le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
à la réunion près de quarante huit mille
personnes s'occupent quotidiennement
d'un parent âgées handicapées ou en
situation de dépendance
ce sont les aidants familiaux pour les
soutenir et valoriser leur travail
une journée nationale a été créé en leur
honneur à cette occasion le département
organisé trois jours de festivités au
village corail à saint gilles
[Musique]
comme tous les soirs à saint denis
rosemay accueille sa fille de retour de
son foyer d'accueil spécialisé et comme
tous les soirs c'est l'épreuve de force
pour regagner leurs appartements premier
étage
sonia souffrent de handicap psychomoteur
et a du mal à se déplacer seule depuis
36 ans c'est sa mère qui l'aide au
quotidien
[Musique]
pas facile le matap lillois pour
descendre la rd117 rose mais est ce
qu'on appelle une aidante familiale elle
s'occupe en permanence de sa fille sont
en fait tous voilà tout ça se voit
qu'ils ferment ce qui donne tout
simplement j'ai tout ça si on a tout
fait pour elle une situation que
personne n'a choisi mais à laquelle
heureusement s'est adapté du mieux
qu'elle a pu malgré les difficultés
quotidiennes avant sont corrompus
andrieu encore encore voilà le pc avec
avoir eu d'enfant le bondy blog d'alain
2003 a porté les mauvais jours comme
rose mais près de quarante mille
personnes sur l'île se consacrent chaque
jour un proche en situation de
dépendance pour soutenir ces aidants
familiaux
une journée nationale a été créée le 6
octobre à la réunion
le département a consacré trois jours à
cet événement au village corail de saint
gilles c'est quoi un aidant c'est une
personne qui s'occupent d'un proche de
sa famille
on peut avoir un parent à la suite d'un
avc ou d'un accident qui se retrouvent
en perte d'autonomie et donc nous les
enfants ou les frères et soeurs nous
devenons aidant mais nous n'y sommes pas
préparés
ce qui rend la tâche bien plus difficile
et un moment donné et bas ces personnes
on dira finalement qu'ils ont eux aussi
besoin d'être aidé au programme de la
manifestation
conférences et rencontres avec des
psychologues et ateliers de bien-être
pour permettre aux aidants de souffler
l'or ce matin
massage dodo maquillage est fait après
midi je me fais un massage des pieds
micheline s'occupe de son fils mais y
voyant depuis 39 ans mais elle ne
possède le statut d'aidant familial que
depuis quatre ans elle a alors découvert
les différents dispositifs
départementaux mise en place pour
accompagner les familles on a des week
ends répit repos on a des sentiers ont
là le café des aidants
on voit d'autres d'autres d'autres
personnes d'entrer dans et ça donne des
idées
tout le monde parle de leur de leurs
problèmes et on a des conseils et on
peut donner des conseils aussi parce que
il ya beaucoup de cas c'est pas c'est
pas les mêmes quand les mêmes les mêmes
problèmes les familles n'ont pas les
mêmes problèmes rompre l'isolément et
valoriser le dévouement quotidien de ces
aidants c'est le but de ces actions
départementales
je trouve que les aidants ne sont pas
assez valorisés parce qu'ils travaillent
24 heures sur 24 avec leurs proches que
quand on est avec un malade 24 heures
sur 24
quelquefois votre propre vie de famille
et ben soit la face ça fait classe et ça
pose problème
pendant longtemps les aidants familiaux
n'avait pas de statut officiel
ils sont aujourd'hui reconnus ils
peuvent recevoir une compensation
financière selon le cas où faire valoir
leur expérience via une validation des
acquis mais leur principale motivation
reste l'amour de leurs proches
[Musique]
les aidants familiaux sont des personnes
qui s'occupent d'un proche âgés
dépendants ou handicapées
à la réunion on compte environ 48 mille
aidants familiaux pour les soutenir et
leur offrir des moments de répit
le département a mis en place plusieurs
dispositifs le café des aidants un lieu
de rencontres et d'échangés pour les
aidants familiaux
le dispositif répit repos qui permet aux
aidants de partir en séjours pendant un
week end
pour plus d'information vous pouvez
consulter le site du département au
www.pandemia.ch fait 4 point fr lien
social accompagné le réunionnais pour la
mobilité
l'appel elle va la zone 2 ans sur
l'attitude mais l'attitude dans le sud
de l'est de la rue alors la partie donc
tout d'abord bâtie au lycée de saint
joseph pierre poivre pour obtenir mon
bac littéraire donc avec option en
plastique et spécialités donc en
allemand j'avais peur de l'avion en fait
j'ai adoré les aéroports mais j'avais
trop peur de prendre l'avion
j'ai le prélat pour l'avion j'ai franchi
le pas et j'ai quitté mon aile pour 11h
vol est arrivé 6e à paris avec 3 degrés
on a pris l'avion le 20 mars pour des
bacs essai pour commencer mon contrat à
disneyland paris en tant que vendeur en
boutique
un an est à l'honneur puisque j'ai
découvert plano plein de choses j'ai
découvert des personnes extraordinaires
et c'était ça c'était j'ai pu réaliser
mon rêve donc pour l'instant je regrette
pas du tout du tout
et
[Musique]